[Musique]
l'arrivée annoncée de l'épidémie que le
virus fait dans notre système de santé
une matriochka nous faisons face à une
crise dans la crise à l'hôpital
l'hôpital c'est un peu comme votre
gouvernement
quand ceux qui sont en première ligne
sont épuisées il y a de moins en moins
de monde en deuxième ligne pour prendre
le relais temps vous avez assécher les
territoires entre la gestion des
patients courant l'intensification des
urgences le besoin d'espacé isolé
d'accueil pour les patients touchés les
français s'inquiètent de voir nos grands
hôpitaux démunis face à la probable
épidémie postes non pourvus garde à
rallonge personnel en souffrance
c'est toujours la réalité dans nos
établissements de santé malgré vos
mesures d'urgence cette crise ne va
faire qu'aggraver la violence des
déserts médicaux là où les uns après les
autres les hôpitaux de proximité sont
torpillé par le pouvoir central dans la
ruralité mais aussi en banlieue et je le
vois chaque jour dans ma ville de juvisy
la souffrance des urgences de proximité
ne permettra pas d'assurer le bon
fonctionnement de la deuxième ligne
pourtant nécessaire pour éviter la
psychose est traitée correctement
l'arrivée d'une épidémie
personne ne nous a dit que l'hôpital ne
serait pas à la hauteur ou prendre en
charge des malades il a eu il a été dit
là il ya eu déjà en des médecins des
soignants pour nous dire que l'hôpital
était sous tension que l'hôpital avait
besoin de tenir que l'hôpital avait
besoin d'être soutenue évidemment et
c'est ce que nous faisons mais personne
monsieur robert aidé à vous êtes la
première personne à me dire ça depuis
quinze jours
y'a pas un département de france pas un
seul département de france dans lequel
il n'y ait pas un hôpital capable de
prendre en charge l'ensemble des malades
de a à z
nous devons travailler le lien
préhospitalier avec le lien hospitalier
préparé dans l'hypothèse d'une épidémie
le lien entre l'hôpital et la médecine
de ville
tout cela mobilise beaucoup d'énergie
nos soignants sont parmi les meilleurs
soignants du monde parce qu'ils sont
parmi les mieux formés du monde et
qu'ils ont une vocation extrêmement
forte
je crois qu'ici la représentation
nationale s'honorerait à le reconnaître
et à les soutenir
le 49 3
ça n'a jamais été une arme destinée à
museler l'opposition
c'est une arme destinée
muselé la majorité c'est quand le
gouvernement on n'a pas de majorité à
l'assemblée quand il n'est pas sûr de
faire adopter un texte par l'assemblée
qu'il utilise le 49-3 ces mots monsieur
le premier ministre ne sont pas les
miens ce sont les vôtres daté de 2016
puisque vous parlez d'une arme
aujourd'hui ce lb des parlementaires
d'une vème république à bout de souffle
c'est vous qui le dégainer seul contre
tous contre la représentation nationale
contre la majorité des français opposés
à votre texte contre les grévistes et
les manifestants contre les engagements
pris devant les français par le candidat
devenu président et vous voudriez nous
faire porter le chapeau
nous aurions empêcher le débat de fond
vous pouvez prétendre monsieur le député
et après tout je ne peux pas vous en
vouloir
vous pouvez prétendre que discuter de
savoir si analogue doit être remplacé
par rapport à similaires ou similaires
remplacé par rapport à un analogue
vous pouvez discuter de savoir si chaque
année et plus intelligent pour parler
des retraites des français que
annuellement
vous avez le droit c'est vrai il me
paraît à moi monsieur le député et il me
semble que je peux aussi le considérer
que ce débat est un débat d'obstruction
et puisque vous avez voulu commencer
votre question en pointant d'éventuelles
différences entre ce qui a été dit hier
et ceux qui seraient assumés aujourd'hui
permettez moi de vous renvoyer au
président de votre propre président de
groupe qui il n'y a pas trois ans il n'y
a pas deux ans il y a deux semaines
disait que l'objectif de votre groupe
s'était littéralement de procéder à de
l'obstruction et qui aujourd'hui deal
inverse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]